à l'espace jacqueline auriol des
clayes-sous-bois les petites mains
s'affairent pour confectionner un cadeau
et pas n'importe lequel puisqu'il est
fait main les participantes s'attaque à
une composition florale de quoi égayer
ses tables de fêtes de zama règle des
des boules de ou du gypsophile du
branchage de noël des bâtons de cannelle
des boules des rondelles de d'orange et
de pommes
j'adore ça j'adore tout ce qui est
loisirs créatifs
cet atelier était dirigée par une
fleuriste de villepreux qui veille à
prendre des fleurs de saison ce sont des
compositions de noël faites à base
d'amaryllis une fleur de saison une
fleurs à bulbes donc là ce sont des
amarres et les scoops et que l'on pique
dans de la mousse et après que l'on
agrémentent avec des pleins de
décorations de noël du sapin des petites
boules
des des fleurs fraîches également avec
de lézian tue son ami
et on a mis également après plein de
petits sujets le fait main est loin
d'être dépassé un autre atelier cartes
de voeux en scrapbooking étaient
proposées la grande vente va être comme
ça
la toute petite de 2 cm de large
elle va être ici et là cette partie là
le bout on va le coller sur la bande
le matériel était mis à disposition
ainsi que le savoir faire de chacune
une fois qu'on a le matériel c'est
d'abord d'avoir un papier de fond style
papier canson un papier de déco et puis
d embellissement
après les étapes techniques place à la
décoration papier ruban stickers les
créatrices avait tout cela disposition
pour laisser cours à leur imagination
c'est du plaisir
safran et puis ça passe le temps et puis
voir pu voir comment on fait ça s'écarte
créer sa propre carte de ses mains
permet un cadeau personnalisé
il ya le plaisir de faire il ya le
plaisir d'offrir parce que je sais que
les gens auxquels j'offre des gens
voient des cas les gardent donc ça déjà
ça m'a fait plaisir
comptez entre une à trois heures pour
concevoir sa carton scrapbooking enfin
terminée les participantes étaient ravis
je suis fier tout simplement
ces deux ateliers met en évidence une
des valeurs de noël le partage avec ses
proches